thank you
[Music]
has anybody seen the omaze uh drawings
you know those like Raffles or whatever
yeah yeah yeah those are crazy yeah yeah
are they a scam they got some of the
sickest cars and [ __ ] on there they're
not a scam they're so cool yeah they
have the coolest [ __ ] they have the
culture has anybody answered one no I
should though I've always I I get cold
feet I answered one one time and then I
I didn't hear anything I just spent like
100 bucks and that was the end of it but
I really really wanted to win a bunch of
things from because they have the
coolest things they have like what was
it what was it would you intern that one
I think was like a custom plaid uh model
X oh that's sweet but you know how like
there's there's a like legit the
thickest cars yeah souped up wheels
everything yeah it's [ __ ] beautiful
it's like one-on-one type [ __ ] and they
also started doing homes yeah I saw that
people I saw one in like Austin Texas
and it was like a super sweet Decked Out
home and then all the comments people
were just pissed off they're mad because
they're like well you're giving away
free home but we have to pay for all
this you know we have to pay taxes and
the property tax they're like yeah this
would be a dream like oh yeah you give
me this Rolex notable by expensive case
for me this is [ __ ]
okay you can't even give away free [ __ ]
and people are gonna be [ __ ] pissed
that that is a truth but I think the
perspective of this particular couple
was just way more smart and uh obviously
um they were happy about it why is this
question if you guys got uh gifted a
sick ass path like imagine your dream
path yeah and then you want this amazing
but it's like I don't know Tennessee or
some other state would you be like [ __ ]
it I'll figure out a way to make it work
over there or would you be like no way I
know I pulled up like I uh what's the
word politely decline
this offer yeah for money I think it
would be fun to try for a little bit
just just because it puts you in a new
scenario and it's kind of interesting
maybe I would do like one year but
during that year I would probably fix it
up in order for it to be like rented
right I'm sure there's a way you could
figure that out especially with a crazy
pad like that yeah because you just keep
it rent it out make money and then have
that Monies
the community that it's in so that you
could price it accordingly you have a
sweet home like because you see some of
these houses on Airbnb they're like 700
a night a thousand dollars a night for
like a really sweet pad with all the
amenities you could ask for so you rent
that out the proper way you make some
good money I think it'd be a cool life
experience why are you gonna gift us a
house yeah yeah no oh you let it on that
way your house
man [ __ ] up a close escrow yet
[ __ ]
so
it's good it's good that you ask because
uh this particular couple they actually
entered an omaze competition what and
they won
they won an incredible 3.3 million
dollar dream home oh and this Mansion
[ __ ] that's a lot right
um and then Weeks Later
they put up for sale are you allowed to
do that wow you can do it that fast
that's how you gotta hold on to it or
some [ __ ] uh this this uh Indian couple
utan Palmer scooped a four bedroom
Cornish house with panoramic Estuary
views
um what city Tennessee no no this was uh
this is a Cornish house in the UK
actually umiz worse uh Cornish house uh
they entered a million pound house straw
as well as a more um and as well as a
mortgage free house with uh all stamp
Duty and legal fees covered they were
also given 50 000 pounds in cash to help
settle in for winning this competition
that's cool yeah what I'm gonna enter in
every single one yeah sick but despite
obviously being [ __ ] thrilled that
they won this jackpot just a couple
months ago in August actually eight
weeks later they decided to sell and
list the home uh which has Gordon Ramsay
as a neighbor in this neighborhood damn
or uh it smells good for 4.4 million uh
or 4.4 four pounds um four million
British pounds that's what it is
um so he is 50 years old his wife is 53
they've returned to their regular four
bedroom home uh in uh their own City
their regular town where they've
normally lived I say regular as a spot
thing but basically not this [ __ ]
Gordon Ramsay neighborhood Village yeah
and they said uh it's a fantastic house
and a beautiful Cornish location but the
price of it comes with the price to keep
it and we can't afford to so we're
selling it and not keeping it as a
holiday home we considered moving there
and staying there but with all the costs
Etc it was a lot so we decided to sell
it wow dude that is such a like an
Indian sensibility like of logic I love
it yeah for sure like yeah super
rational I remember when I was in high
school uh one of my buddies he has like
this mansion in Fullerton
and um this is like when you know when
you're like when you slowly start
hanging out with other people in other
cities then your bubble kind of gets
bursted and you start to understand the
world a little bit more so we were at
this full's house and his the lot was
probably like 20 30 000 square feet and
then we all like slept over I remember
eating at the his like breakfast nook or
whatever we're eating and all of a
sudden I see some full like [ __ ]
descend from outside I'm like oh [ __ ]
did someone else say what the [ __ ] he
goes oh that's just my windows cleaners
like what what the [ __ ] I'm used to like
maybe a gardener or something but you
got some dude like upside down with the
squeegee and and I'm like dude we have
lived completely different lives yeah
it's 100
you just thought this was like SWAT
coming in to [ __ ] smash the windows
you're not used to seeing people upside
down you know coming down the window so
it just it caught me off guard like what
the [ __ ] going on and then he was like
oh it's just and it was just so
nonchalant like that's that's my my
window cleaners I've never known new no
window cleaning my whole life a window
cleaner yeah
what about you how does it feel to be
rich
so I I have a thing when you were saying
that I I went to my friend's house in um
in I in San Diego somewhere like North
San Diego and that was the first time
ever that I went to a house that looks
like um
it's like it was so [ __ ] big it's
like they have re like hallways and
railings
I've never seen that before that was
like this house in Vegas yeah he has
that too you got like a bridge oh no but
yeah it was like two I remember that's
the biggest house I've ever went to it
was like um
it's like a a store like a abercromb
like a really big Abercrombie store but
like nothing's out of place right you
need a map for sure I'm not good wow
like one of those you are here things
yeah where's the back at the mall where
am I oh it's here yeah that was it I
would never forget that that's so crazy
the people's houses what did that guy do
but that would be really skit no that
was what um it was a girl but uh but
it's like yeah I don't know what he did
it was like high school times but uh
yeah that was so so big
damn yeah
that was the end of the day
yeah the way that you said that uh it's
a very um probably like an Indian
sentiment to be like that rational sick
I would have to admit that I don't know
if I would immediately think that
rationally yeah no I I don't think I
would either you did just know because
you they were asking you oh but you were
immediately like even more rational than
me that's like that's immediately
selling it that's like really cool
because they almost see like all the
costs right away yeah like you know for
me I wouldn't even know what the costs
were until I see okay there's so this
house needs a window cleaner oh do you
need like a [ __ ] I don't know
whatever
handmaiden whatever the [ __ ] those names
are I don't know I don't know those you
just have all these like chamber made
chambermaids yeah you have all these
titles that you're like oh like a Jester
yeah yeah like the uh secretary they
need some some houses need staff you
know that's true and they're like whoa
that's crazy well because also the
um somebody did instant math and said
it's worth a lot now because it's in
this condition but without the
maintenance when you do want to sell it
it's going to cost a lot to bring it
back up to Value so I'm like that's
[ __ ] smart because the time is now
yeah it's like if you wait a year and
you don't hire the staff like we were
saying to upkeep it then that you're
just your values went down and it's cool
that they don't have any like
restrictions on that at least that we
know of so far right Anthony
um the idea that this has gone out and
that he's actually able to list it like
proves that he's got everything
available to him right it's like almost
got all those sweepstakes and stuff you
gotta like hold on to whether it's a car
or a boat or whatever I thought so too I
thought there was like a stipulation
that you had to like no I would assume
that like when it's yours and you've
paid your
um taxes and stuff on it you're good oh
you know what I'm saying because like I
remember I won a [ __ ] a Macbook doing
a video contest dude congrats 2000 yeah
it was really really fun
um I did a stupid dance video uh it was
a stupid dude it's probably still online
it wasn't stupid okay I want a Macbook
and then I was like oh [ __ ] like I
[ __ ] won something and it was like in
the value was like a thousand dollars so
afterwards I still got a thing that said
I had to pay like 253 dollars in taxes
for the MacBook I remember thinking to
myself I was like you know but this is
my first time winning something so I was
like
that's weird yeah this is [ __ ] you
know what I mean I was like that doesn't
make sense I thought I won this but yeah
but you got to pay the tax on it so I'm
guessing if you win something like that
like a giant house he's probably gotta
still pay something for it whether it be
the upkeep and or the taxes or something
because it's like yeah it's like income
you know but that probably should also
give them the right to sell it so you
can pay for those things because he owns
it if he has to pay tax money he owns it
right yeah but what if yeah what if he
worked like at a grocery store and he
couldn't afford you know to do all those
things then he has to sell it flip it
right away no right that's true don't
they usually like for some of these
sweepstakes they give you like a stack
of cash to help you cover tax like by
law they gave him 50 000 pounds as well
but pretty sweet that's why when they do
those things like win this custom Jeep
and 60 000 in Cold Hard Cash it's like
oh it's so that it's a lot more
attractive to enter it because you're
like ran someone over in this Jeep
ignore the blood spray yeah but even
then the cash is like doesn't even cover
all the tags and then you gotta pay for
the cash too you got to get taxed on the
cash well the strange thing is I always
wonder if the valuation of the car is
like kind of inflated because of all the
custom work they've done versus like
it's just a standard uh retail Jeep
Renegade or something I mean what even
what omaze does though is or I don't
know if omaze for sure does but I feel
like a lot of sweepstakes do this like
let's say you win the car like oh you
won this car and the car's value is like
ninety thousand dollars I think you can
like opt to just take 40 000 cash not
take the car sometimes sometimes they
give you like a way way like cheaper
cash option of a win and they get to
redo the raffle anyway so basically read
the fine print yeah I mean if you're
happy with what you get
what's the crime or sell it if you know
that you can [ __ ] sell it for a
profit there was a there was a cool dude
that I met
um at car shows he had this like really
sweet like Lamborghini and uh he was
kind of like socially awkward and a
little bit like like weird and we used
to always ask him like dude what do you
do like how do you have such a nice car
and he would always go I I just bag
groceries and everyone would laugh and
go Ah that's [ __ ] funny like but then
we would always go no really like what
are you doing he's like I really just
bagged groceries he just kept saying
that and so it was like okay he [ __ ]
owns a supermarket or some [ __ ] turns
out like about a year after I known this
guy people were like no that's really
his job this dude won the lotto while he
was working at a grocery store and he
kept working us and he has a [ __ ]
Lamborghini yeah that's [ __ ] that's
hot yeah that's cool and then we were
like that's why he's a little awkward
because uh he has all this money but he
doesn't know how to really treat it he's
just trying to enjoy it the way that he
thinks he's supposed to it also seems
like he's not blowing it he's still like
working on a grocery store he still
enjoys his role at the store or he did
and that's why he's still working
I did that rolling up to your freaking
grocery store job in a Lambo
foreign